nous aurons et arrogant il s'était fait
plein de me garder il ya un crétin qui
veut sauter des glaciers de la mort ne
me dis pas que c'est notre crétins nous
attention je compté jusqu'à 3 et ce sont
1 2 si tu ne bouges plus d'un poil on
arrive 2031 miyem qui te et 41 millièmes
si tu arrêtes de faire l'idiot des
samares pas question je veux être le
premier à chanter du glacier de la mort
comme ça vous aurait obéi qu'à une me
témoignant enfin tu respectes situ sont
le seul respectueux optera c'est le
respect qu'on a pour les morts d'un
titre par amman il est pas idiot ce
point là cela dit on n'est jamais sûr de
rien
bonjour
je peux plus respirer j'ai la rate et
michard par les contenus
dgo entre tes griffes s'il te plaît oui
s'ils se connaissaient pas aussi bien
diego se penserait que tu as peur de
l'autre d'accord il pense que tu n'as
pas de perte de l'an waouh les da toni
la tchatche avérée